على حق ، كنت أفكر إذا كنت في
كوريا الجنوبية أو إذا كنت تايوان ، أعتقد أن
الدرس هو أننا بحاجة إلى أن نكون نوويين
كقدرة وإلا فقد
يحدث هذا أيضًا لنا بشكل
صحيح لأن لا أحد يريد
حربًا نووية شاملة بشكل صحيح
وبوتين  استخدم تهديداته النووية بشكل
فعال للغاية وقد أبلغه فورًا أنه
في اليوم الرابع من الحرب
سحب البطاقة النووية أو حتى في
خطابه افتتاح
الغزو
الذي يذكره مرارًا وتكرارًا
ثم رفع أه
مستوى جاهزية قواته الرادعة الإستراتيجية
وهي تعمل أه تعمل على إبقاء الناتو
والولايات المتحدة خارج البلاد
وما ندركه أيضًا
أننا قضينا الكثير من الوقت في التفكير في
كيفية عمل هذا الردع بين
دولتين نوويتين مسلحتين.  لقد
قضينا وقتًا كافيًا تقريبًا في التفكير في كيفية
ردع استخدام نووي من قبل دولة نووية
ضد دولة غير حائزة للأسلحة النووية ، ولا
يوجد ما يمنع بوتين من استخدام
سلاح نووي تكتيكي أو أي
سلاح آخر.  و الدمار الشامل ضد
أوكرانيا اليوم
دكتور بدجرين السؤال الأخير 30
ثانية فقط فكيف إذن نحمي
من التصعيد الذي أشك أنا وأنت في
أنه قادم
أه لا توجد إجابة سهلة على هذا
السؤال أعتقد أن الكثير هو الكتابة
عن نتيجة هذا  الحرب إذا انتصرت أوكرانيا
وتمكنت بطريقة ما من دفع
روسيا للخارج وإذا ساعدها الغرب على
ذلك ، فالرواية هي أن
الأسلحة النووية ربما ليست ضرورية ،
وربما يمكنك هزيمة دولة تمتلك
أسلحة نووية دون امتلاك
أسلحة نووية إذا سقطت أوكرانيا
ثم اممم.
ثم ستكتسب الأسلحة النووية
قيمة مختلفة جدًا في العالم
الذي درسته أه كلا هذين
الصراعين على نطاق واسع ، لقد كتبت مقال رأي
حول هذا على موقع cnn.com وهناك
يوجد الرقم الذي يعرض
فلاديمير بوتين للخطر  دعنا نتحدث
عن بداية الحرب بداية
الغزو الروسي لأفغانستان بعض
أوجه التشابه أه ما الذي تراه
جيدًا أعني أعتقد أن التشابه الكبير
أعني لفلاديمير  بوتين ، التشابه الكبير هو
أن 15000 جندي روسي ربما لقوا حتفهم
وفقًا
لتقديرات مسؤولي الناتو حتى الآن.
الأرقام الرسمية خلال حرب 1980 ضد
السوفيتات هي 15000 جندي روسي قتلوا
في تسع سنوات من الحرب خلال الثمانينيات
خمسة عشر ألفًا روسي  جنود ماتوا
في شهر واحد من الحرب في أوكرانيا خمسة عشر
ألف جندي من جنود أه
الروس ماتوا الآن فهم فلاديمير بوتين
أن جدار برلين سقط
عندما انسحبت السوفيتات من
أفغانستان وهو يعلم أنه ليس من
قبيل الصدفة أنه كان
ضابطًا شابًا في الكي جي بي في شرق ألمانيا  في ذلك
الوقت كان حدثًا مؤثرًا في حياته ،
لذلك يجب أن يكون مدركًا تمامًا أنك تعرف
أن الأشياء لا يمكن أن تتغير في مصلحته إذا
بدأت أكياس الجثث الكافية في العودة إلى المنزل
والعودة إلى الوراء في التاريخ الروسي ،
فأنت تعرف أن الرومانوف
خسروا الحرب العالمية.  واحد أه هم تعلمون
أولاً وقبل كل شيء تنازل عن العرش ثم تم
إعدامه ، لذا فإن بوتين يدرك جيدًا هذا
التاريخ الروسي أنه إذا فشلت في الحروب
فقد يكون ذلك ممكنًا.  تكون مشكلة كبيرة بالنسبة لك
نفسك